a costume department keeps track of
everything they make we keep track of
the buttons that we make it with here's
pantone's for camp nowhere there's our
roast beef logo how cute here's the made
to order sheet for karen wheeler's
bathing suit so we go from here to here
hi i'm amy parris costume designer of
stranger things and i'm excited to show
you some of my work
[Music]
season four knowing that we'd be in four
different huge locations i wanted to
definitely make sure the color palette
like showed through the screen so we
made sure that the stock was specific
for each location we knew that russia
would be like darker and scarier so we
made sure that those clothes really
reflected that in the uniforms hawkins
is still its classic like dusty rusty
but with saturated colors so we made
sure to really like make it pop between
each frame i definitely leaned into the
movies of the 80s that like reflected
high school kids like tough turf or one
of the guys and used that and yearbooks
from the location in the region so if it
was california we were looking at
california yearbooks and when we were
doing hawkins we were doing like midwest
yearbooks from like 84 to 86 so that
we'd really make sure we were following
the right trends of the time ali sheedy
for the breakfast club was a huge
inspiration for eden brook shields was
an influence for nancy molly ringwald
was an influence for our new character
vicky part of our process is building
stuff that we need multiples for so
often we'll make fabrics or
boots or belts or hats and so i often
use like a fabric printer and we take
our fabric samples and our colors and we
find out what works best for the outfit
you might recognize this as the
milkshake dress from 11 in the roller
rink scenes and we knew we wanted a kind
of like soft linen fabric so we printed
it on multiple styles just to make sure
it would have the right hand and the
right feel i think mine and my team's
eye is so trained to see 80s clothing we
really do use real vintage pieces almost
entirely for stock you need to be head
to toe like authentic to the period
otherwise it'll stand out it'll show
11.
it felt important to make her feel
mismatched because
she's trying to figure out who she is in
this new space you know being in
california let alone being in a new high
school you're trying to fit in and so
you definitely try different outfits you
try different friend groups you try
different things to see where you fit
and so it was important to show that
she'd have pieces that might have been
hand-me-downs from joyce might have been
borrowed from will maybe even
hand-me-downs from jonathan and she
doesn't have max there either so she may
have some leftover pieces from the mall
like the milkshake dress but she doesn't
know that it's weird to pair it with
will's old shirt you know so it's
important that even in the frame with
will she'd kind of look like she's
wearing his clothes but then also threw
a dress on it that she's like well this
this goes right
[Music]
wipe out
we found the best thing to do was to
actually throw a real milkshake on it
and our prop master nico physically
threw it on the dress that we had on a
dress form and we loved the way it
looked the duffers loved it so we
thought well let's let it dry and see
what happens it dried and it dried well
and so we actually use that and that's
the dress she's actually wearing
physically it has real milkshake dried
on it then of course you need multiples
because she's wearing it a photo devil's
wearing it a stunt person is wearing it
so to match we had our age or dire gayle
paint an exact replica of the milkshake
on the dresses so that each one matched
the roller rink was so special and
different we did that at the end of the
season shirts are custom made they also
of course have like the custom graphic
but we couldn't find this shape of a
shirt for the men and the women so we
just built them the shorts are um
special velveteen shorts which are
vintage but the trim was not pink which
matches the jacket so we had to take off
the trim and replace it with the new
trim the jackets were custom made we put
custom ribbing and put the wrinkle mania
logo on the back and then what you don't
really see is a lot of the employees
have these cute little suspenders that
have little like roller skates on them
so even if you don't see a detail it's
there
[Music]
it was kind of last minute but we knew
that we needed a blood splatter and i
felt like the best way to achieve it was
to physically drag something in blood
and it was at night and i'm about
milli size so i figured i'll throw it on
and then i let my assistants drag me
through the blood so we set up a table
uh cloth on the floor and put like blood
puddles and we talked to the ads we
talked to the duffers we asked what it
would look like and how the blood
pattern would go and it was still
a work in progress and we knew we needed
to see the blood first so
they strapped belts on my ankles and
then pulled me through the blood pattern
sort of in the way that we anticipated
them doing and then took the picture and
showed it to them and got approval so
that is also something she's wearing
because it's actually the real like
pattern to what it would have been
steve harrington
we knew that it was time for them to get
out of scoops ahoy so it was nice to
give them a uniform that's a uniform but
still could show their own clothes
underneath so we thought the best way to
do that was with a vest so we took some
creative licensing in making the vest
but it's you know green and orange
that's a thing you could put over any
outfit and it's a uniform but still it
shows their personality through so it
was nice to be able to to get to do that
and let them shine
with steve he's classic steve you know
polo shirts he looks good in jeans he's
been wearing those levi's jeans like
kind of all seasons and they fit him so
well because joke here he doesn't
age or get any bigger he's just sort of
this magical human that stays like
pristine so like we keep giving him the
same jeans and he keeps wearing them i
gave him a different jacket this season
i gave him like a more 80s
gray jacket which kind of echoes the
members only gray jacket but kind of it
made it even more 80s i mean they're
both so iconic and they're both so 80s
but it was nice to kind of just
move it and make it familiar and gray
but make it a little more like exciting
in 80s
jim hopper
the russia stuff was really challenging
but really rewarding i had never worked
internationally and we went to lithuania
so we were able to source costumes in
poland from hero costume ahead of time
so you heard from that
yeah they arrived last night
they're meeting really soon all goes
well
for tomorrow night you're home
eating answers with your sexy woman
she's not my mom
of course not
she saves your life because of
friendship you can't get a plethora of
like russian prisoner uniforms to use on
an american tv show so we knew we'd have
to build them and we made name tags and
sean levy actually came up with the idea
to have david's a custom name tag it
says american in cyrillic so those
uniforms the fabric is meant to last for
russian prisoners that should be durable
so imagine breaking down freshly new
outfits that should be on camera but
look like they've been around for 40 to
50 years i mean that is so much work for
our ager dyers you have to take out the
color you have to add distressing you
have to add dirt and grime so we were
working on those up until they were on
camera and even then some adding dirt on
top and like constantly trying to take
them down because they're so rich in
color that you almost have to go further
so the camera sees the distress and the
dirt so it was a lot of work i mean
physically just like pounding on those
uniforms it's it's a lot it's a it's a
whole other color palette you know it's
like the dark the blue the green the
scary the dark red you know we used
authentic hats we used authentic pieces
as much as we could the gloves are real
david's uniform he needed about six of
them in addition to just like
distressing these outfits for all the
prisoners then it's distressing them for
the actors to have at least like six or
more so it's it's a lot of work
dustin henderson
yeah it's been exciting to get to change
his hat up because it is such an iconic
piece for him i knew i wanted to do
something different because he's not in
camp so the thinking cap felt like a hat
that he'd find at the mall and buy the
scantron shirt was a fabric that i found
in atlanta at a fabric store that it's
like bubbles that i thought i could see
dustin like sitting in class getting
bored and filling that in so we made
this shirt and i talked to gayton about
it and i said can you imagine dustin
doing that he was like oh yeah of course
so my friend trevor who made the
hellfire logo actually did the artwork
on the shirt
no no no no no no no
no food
what are you doing man setting up face
of operation too face of operations stop
get off of that i need it need it for
what looking up eddie's friend's phone
numbers oh eddie my new best friend
eddie you think he's cooler than me
because he plays a nerdy game
i never said that this is exciting
because it's kind of like zelda type in
imagery you know like video game stuff
so there's a castle and
like a viking shooting arrows at an elf
with a guy on a horse and then it
connects to the back which has this fire
breathing dragon and there's a wizard
down here which is a lot like the will
wizard from season three
eddie munson
the hellfire club we knew we wanted it
to look like the boys in the club made
the shirt so we were really specific
about the logo you know we used research
and images of young d d club players so
i knew a lot of them had white with
black sleeves just because it also pops
and then you can see the logo really
well so we tried black with white
sleeves we tried red but really the one
that stood out the most was the white uh
base and the black sleeves so then we
built on that and we found a leather
jacket by the brand shot and that was
the perfect slim jacket that could be
over his shirt but then have a vest on
top and so the vest is a vintage levi's
trucker blanket line jacket somebody had
cut the sleeves off so it had the right
amount of fray there's distressing on
the collar everything about it was the
perfect level of like worn in he's
probably had it forever kind of guy
absolutely not you asked for a sub
we delivered this is hellfire club
not babysitting club i'm 11 you
long-haired freak my my the child speaks
we added a belt buckle that has like a
handcuff on it we gave him his reebok
sneakers with the tongues pulled out
because he would have done that in the
80s we gave him like a chain on the
leather of his jacket like maybe the
zipper broke and he tried to like close
it so we really focused on little
details he listens to that wizard medal
he has d.o on the back and that is
actually a gift from the estate of
ronnie james dio his ex-wife wendy sent
us vintage shirts and sweatshirts and
stuff that we were able to use so yeah
this is our exciting eddie vest that we
love we kind of stitched it so it would
look like he did it himself some of the
pins we had to like tech down so they
wouldn't be so bright and shiny on
camera but they're all vintage pins of
bands that he would have been a fan of
in the 80s we have iron maiden
mega death motorhead judas priest wasp
except merciful fate this is the
levithian cross this is in the back of
his pants this is like the vintage
custom handkerchief and his handcuff
belt buckle which we also had to like
tech down so it wouldn't be so shiny oh
yeah this is our original do patch on
the back
we did need about five eddies at one
point because eddie also gets dirty he
gets you know like black blood from the
bat fight so you have a clean you have a
dirty eddy you also need to have the
vest that goes to
jokiri and so there's a jokiri vest as
eddie and then that's dirty so it was a
challenge but it was so worth it he's
the perfect eddie he really is
joy spires
it was such a different element knowing
we were going to lithuania to shoot
lithuania as russia and our intention
was to keep our actors as warm as
possible we knew they'd be freezing and
we knew we'd be stuck in these clothes
for a while so
we had tried building in like heat packs
like electronic heater that was like
built inside the outfit to keep them
warm
that would work at times we made sure we
gave them hats and like comfort gear but
i wanted to make sure winona would stay
warm as a human in a really cold climate
she has a lot of ideas for the
characters and she knows the character
best so it's nice to kind of have a
formula and to know a fit the jacket
does a good job of like being a feminine
like mom coat that she would have had
from hawkins and then brought to
california but never wore since because
you wouldn't need a coat in california
there's like a science to like the fit
of the pants now we know exactly like
where they sit on the waist exactly how
they bail out over the shoes we probably
won't ever get her out of a white reebok
sneaker
i mean those are her shoes those are
joyce all seasons i'm sure
nancy wheeler
there's like a hint into nancy's dress
that that dress that had the purple
dress with the teal we had to remake
that because we needed a double so the
original that she wears is vintage but
then the stunt one is not
or here's her shirt that we made for
them all nancy is now getting a little
more serious with school she's getting
ready to go to college and so we kept
her still in her sweet pastel color
palette it was nice to make her feel
even more mature than just dresses like
we did last season
and the striped shirt i enjoy keeping
her battle outfits and stripes because
season one and two had her in that so
season three she's in stripes at the
mall so i knew i wanted to keep her in
stripes for this season
and we knew that there was a moment
where she would need to rip off
a part of her outfit to help steve when
he's hurt during the
bat bite
so it started off as the cowl neck but
we noticed that that was a little
complicated and the continuity of that
mixed with like having a raw edge around
her face so much of tv is here that i
kind of didn't want to distract the
audience with like looking at this like
ripped shirt all the time so we
progressed it and found it was better
for it to come off the ribbing at the
bottom of the shirt so we had a lot of
tests with that making sure that we
could sort of like score the fabric and
make it easy for natalia to rip on the
day the cowl neck and the ribbing was
custom dyed to match the stripes so that
it would be the right color and then
once it's built and aged and dirtied
then it's like pre-cut so that she could
rip it easily
now you know what they
say those who get to
teach
[Music]
uh
yes
yes that's actually why we're here
nancy's outfit is all made from scratch
we made the shirt and the little
two-piece set which has a cute little
wrap-around belt and then maya's is a
custom shirt and skirt it's just the
only original vintage piece is the
sweater and we did have to remake it in
multiples for the girls the sweater we
cheated for the for the like driving
double and we gave a very close match
but luckily it's driving double so you
don't see that it's not the perfect
match we got to make custom boots for
nancy this season that have a matching
belt and we did that with jitterbug boy
in canada so that was fun to be able to
have the time to do that because i knew
she'd need boots but i knew there
weren't really any current boots that
have enough 80s details that are
passable so i said let's make them so we
did
my wheeler
that's a rad shirt man ocean pacific oh
hey mike this is uh my friend ergo oh
hey
oh no no no
no it's a shitty knockoff yeah don't
sweat it man i'll get you the good
threads out here so mike wheeler's
outfit was written into the script that
way and it was written that our guy
would go oh hey cool shirt so we knew
we'd wanted something that felt like an
outfit maybe he would have bought at the
airport before he got there so it's kind
of hokey you know it says surf on the
back and there's surfboards and it's
bright it's not a color that mike
normally wears and he would have
accessorized it with a hat and
sunglasses with croakies knowing he was
going to be outside in the sun he wears
flip-flops and the outfit was actually
manufactured by quicksilver we had a
collaboration with them which was really
helpful because during pandemic we
couldn't make clothes fast enough we had
made two colorways we made orange and
teal and he's worn teal before so it
felt like orange was the best color that
was different from his closet that felt
like he was trying to make it work in
california
[ __ ] he seems really revved up tonight
he's always rubbed out
we'll just
cash out
casual casual right okay
totally
it's interesting because he's definitely
influenced by eddie so we added a little
darkness to his clothes like he's
wearing black jeans this season he's
also wearing converse which it feels
like something that he thought eddie
would probably wear it's cool to kind of
slowly edge him a little bit darker and
a little less preppy you know maybe his
mom's not buying all of his clothes now
the shirt that he's wearing in teal has
you know like the diamond shape and so
the angles of the shirt are a little
more edgier so it's like you're
physically seeing sharper images and
sharper corners on him because he's
turning a little bit edgier
max mayfield
[Music]
she's still in mourning her brother had
passed not too long ago so
we had done this first outfit the outfit
of the grid pattern shirt with the
sweatshirt and is a little brighter than
i think i would have wanted it to be
looking back but it was right as we were
like coming back from pandemic and i
think we were all trying to figure out
how to keep the show going and it had
been in the works so it is what it is
but later on the next outfit is a little
darker which reflects that she really is
kind of in mourning and trying to cover
up so the outfit is kind of baggy the
jeans are kind of baggy you know she's
kind of trying to hide it and protect
herself in her clothes we had made this
outfit the grid shirt was made and then
the sweatshirt was made but the second
outfit is a hang 10
corduroy jacket with a target shirt and
again we kind of bought it during
quarantine and it was sort of like you
can get what you can get and so shopping
was really limited and so we only had a
couple and then we found out we needed
so many more so we have our shopper
caroline hodge who's wonderful she
combed through the internet and found
every possible target green striped
shirt she could on poshmark so she she
did end up finding quite a few you know
those are the challenges that you have
to overcome when you're dealing with
multiples and things selling before you
know that you need that many part of the
the way to avoid that is to build it
yourself to have the control of like
printing the fabric
or making the boots or finding the
leather like doing the stuff yourself so
that you know you can recreate it
because this is a show where you kind of
don't always know what's going to happen
lucas sinclair
i found out that lucas would sort of be
a jock type in reading the script so it
was a balance of figuring out how he's
kind of jock and kind of hanging out
with you know jason and those guys but
still part of the d d club so he's sort
of you know between friend groups and
balancing that out we were able to give
him custom converse sneakers that
converse made for us he wears those with
the uniform that was also custom made
for lucas the balance of making his
outfits still kind of nerdy d and then
kind of jock-like allowed us to make him
a little bit sportier and add you know
like kind of an athletic look to his
clothes it was important to like make
sure it felt like an outfit that wasn't
too nerdy wasn't too cool it was a
balance
murray balman
[Music]
aren't you a lot of cypher sore eyes huh
hi murray kids like risotto
yeah
yeah the apron was actually uh that
that's props to props that's props to
nico he found that apron we had smaller
vintage like women's aprons that
in theory would have maybe been joyce's
and she's a petite person so
we had tinier ones but they were almost
too tiny so it was nice to have like a
more substantial bib apron and that was
shawn levy he was like i want to be able
to see it up here so we found this bib
apron that is so perfect it totally
looks like an apron she would have had
also so
that was a props prop so thank you props
and will you please stop trying to talk
to me and stay in character remember you
are frightened scared confused yes i am
frightened scared okay all right yes
marie's really exciting and one of my
favorites because most of that is custom
made
we started knowing that we'd need to
have layers that would be revealed so we
had we were between two coats a teal
coat or a brown coat and the teal was
best because it's worn with this
beautiful hand-knit sweater that was
hand knit for the show um it kind of has
that golden mustard color worn with a
brown turtleneck this is murray
traveling so murray might dress up
because now he's like outside of his
house which he's kind of a hermit so
when he's outside it's nice to see him
get kind of gussied up back in the 80s
you used to kind of dress up a little
bit more for traveling so we gave him a
gold chain
you know he's single maybe he's out to
meet people
robin buckley
[Music]
so that is a wrangler's jacket that we
knew we wanted to give the girls some
layers because we knew they'd have to
eventually
lose jackets when they jump into the
water and it was nice to give maya a
little like diy chance to kind of put
her own spin on it so we grabbed an
assortment of like vintage patches and
was like what do you like you know so
she actually my hand picked those
patches and we talked about where we
would place them it felt real it felt
like what robin would do with maya's
influence the yellow over shirt that she
wears for quite a while and the season
has like a leaf print and then we we
custom printed it so i added some
triangles and some equality symbols to
kind of have an easter egg that there's
some lgbtq plus imagery within her
outfit you know i thought that was
important to help represent her for that
oh my gosh those are cool so those
outfits are legit like 80s uniforms so i
think it's marchinglinks.com there's a
website that you can actually go to all
the piping in the band uniforms are like
hand painted orange the feathers on
their caps those are custom made with
like orange tips and we added the little
patches the cumber buns all had to be
like hand painted and hand dyed to be
the right color
[Music]
i can't breathe in this thing and i'm
itchy i'm itching all over it's so cute
right that was fun to get to do because
maya was excited to show something
that's like not a typical robin moment
and so we were collaborating on that
like how it should feel around the neck
and how tight it should be i think it
turned out beautifully and i think
maya's performance in it really helps
and that's always nice to be able to
lend the clothes to the actor's
performance for her to say i'm
uncomfortable in this you know to like
use that and help them aid in in
something that's uncomfortable or
something that feels good or bad it's
nice to be able to use the costume to
help the actor give that performance
will byers
[Music]
he's the youngest of the boys and he's
grown the most and matured a lot in this
last season and with the pandemic and
with the break in between you definitely
see an age progression especially in his
face but also in his body you know like
there's more muscle definition and stuff
so you kind of you either need to lean
into that or lean away from it so we hit
his arms a little bit just to help hide
that
but between season three and four he was
in stripes a lot for season three and so
i kind of brought back the plaid for
season four because he's in hawkins
which is a little bit more fashion
forward so it was nice to have kind of
that old plaid style still running
through his character
argyle
that was fun to do because it is so
different from anything we've done so
it's authentic
pieces that are either recreated by
quicksilver from the 80s which was
really nice to get to do and collaborate
with them on or it's like vintage stuff
it's hard for him because we needed a
lot of multiples so a lot of things were
made in in doubles or triples
um but you know wearing down the shoes
and giving him like mismatched socks and
pins on his um hat as well like you know
eduardo's wearing bracelets and
some of them were done by like friends
who have daughters that can do like
friendship bracelets i was like can you
ever make like five please
it was nice to make it feel like it was
real i mean he probably would have made
them himself you know like
again it's nice to put yourself in the
mind of the actor and think if they're
bored at high school they're going to
color on their shirt or they're going to
make friendship bracelets or they're
going to find pins that they're going to
put on their clothes so it's nice to
like take the time to be more authentic
that way dead dude
i'm making him a headstone and you do
realize we spent all morning hiding the
body
well i'll just write uh here lies
unknown hero agent man
it's an iconic yellow and right now when
you look up visors they're not as long
and they don't have the terry right and
so inside like especially in california
be warm so it actually has that terry
cloth inside which is a big 80s thing to
do the brim is longer and the like the
height of it is higher than they are now
that helped kind of sell it as more of a
period visor than anything we could find
in the stores right now
and the custom
surfer boy pizza logo that was from the
art department and that was scripted of
course so it was nice to kind of
imagine that a pizza shop in the 80s
would have done like a one color screen
print just pump out these shirts so we
just did red on yellow which is super
graphic and bright and it was you know
why not add the visor and he has his
hair is such a character too you know so
part of my design process for him was to
give him all these bright patterns and
colors knowing you wouldn't see so much
of it because his hair covers it so
logos graphics you know you'd lose them
behind the hair so it was nice to have
stuff that would kind of pop out amongst
it that makes sense
jonathan byers
that was an exciting shirt to get to do
and he was an exciting costume to like
move through because he's in california
now and you know he's kind of like
absorbed this like 420 lifestyle so it
was nice to be able to show that through
the fabric that he was wearing he's in
icat print shirts at the beginning and
then i knew we'd want to build a shirt
that he'd track through because he's in
it for so many episodes so that's a
fabric i found it's like a vintage dead
stock fabric and a store called rag
finders in downtown la we over dyed it
and then built this beautiful shirt that
almost feels psychedelic it was a lot
brighter and i knew we'd need to like
take it down so we over dyed it so it
wouldn't be so bright but it was fun to
kind of feel like you'd look at the
shirt and be like what is that you know
like that's kind of how his mind is as
he's like going through his
4 20 time he's definitely influenced by
argyle so i think you know brightening
him up and giving him a color
it was like kind of the perfect pattern
for this outfit
erica sinclair
[Music]
back in the 80s it was really big on
sets and matching pieces so it's a very
coordinated outfit it's something i
probably would have worn at her age and
so that was fun to get to do we screen
printed the pink fabric and then made
the dress with fabric that we found at
fine fabrics in atlanta i wanted erica
to still look youthful and that's
that's a interesting thing to do because
priya's growing you know she's becoming
a woman she's like you could see it in
her face she's at an age where
personally she wants to look older but
she also should feel the age that she's
supposed to be on camera so it was
tricky to kind of balance that and make
her feel feminine and young and keep her
looking younger than she actually is if
that makes sense yes the american flag
cape is so fun so that's our prop master
nico
he supplied the cape and we had fun in
the fitting like playing around with
that it was written in the script that
she would show up that way so i like
when the script's really specific about
really like big props and costume pieces
like that that's fun to get to add i
think it's also nice that her clothes
are so like like genuine and sweet and
girly but she has such an attitude you
know so you wouldn't expect the mouth of
that girl to look like that it was so
fun to get to do that
dr martin brenner
the work that modine does is a
complicated timeline and so in order to
showcase that and help the viewer know
what timeline we're in we tried to make
sure that the the suits that he's
wearing are very specifically 70s that
wide lapel those long collars you know
the pattern and the tie is specific to
the era so that kind of helps the viewer
to see when it's 70s to when it's 80s or
even at like 60s flashback
vecna
[Music]
after you
[Music]
yeah i mean this was really cool to get
to work with jamie campbell bauer on
this because he's
the perfect vechna and
knowing that this outfit sort of
establishes his character before we find
out who he is it was really important to
make sure that it was really stark
really clean kind of perfect
you know he plays the character so well
i wanted the costume to aid in that so
we made sure the fit was just right
we made sure that it was like perfectly
clean perfectly fit
and kind of creepy you know i think the
the all white with the black belt and
the black shoes does just that
thanks for having me gq i'm amy parris
and those were my fine points